un appartement tout ce qu'il y a de plus
normal sans autre indice de l'endroit où
elle se cache
[Musique]
un refuge pour une jeune femme de 19 ans
qui a fui l'Iran pour rester libre
ma vie comme celle de beaucoup de
personnes est en danger c'est pour ça
que je peux pas révéler où j'habite
[Applaudissements]
début octobre à agva au sud-ouest de
Téhéran comme partout au pays ils sont
nombreux à manifester leur colère contre
le régime en place
dès le début je me suis dit que je ne
suis pas face à des humains je suis face
à des êtres sans humanité ils peuvent
faire n'importe quoi avec moi
parmi da est ici de dos sans hijab les
cheveux teints souvent bien en vue on
finit même par la surnommée la
manifestante aux cheveux rouges en
général j'ai peur de rien
beaucoup de gens disent qu'il faut avoir
peur de Dieu de la religion mais moi j'y
crois pas
après avoir participé à plusieurs
manifestations et les finalement arrêtée
par les autorités qui la surveille
depuis un certain temps
il me soupçonnait d'être une personne
très active politiquement il m'ont
ramené au centre de détention du
ministère de l'Information et de la
sécurité
parmi da passe donc 14 jours en prison à
agvas c'est important centre
industrielle et économique de l'Iran
longuement elle nous raconte son
cauchemar
tous les jours avant l'interrogatoire il
me déshabiller j'avais les yeux bandés
les mains et les pieds liés ils
m'interroger pendant des heures
lorsqu'on me demandait d'écrire mes
aveux je n'avais rien à écrire alors il
déchirait le papier et le mettait dans
ma bouche pendant sa détention elle dit
avoir été harcelée subit des
attouchements sexuels et avoir été
violée
[Musique]
de m'embrasser mais j'ai craché sur lui
il a frappé ma tête au sol à plusieurs
reprises m'a donné des coups de poing
pendant le viol je me suis mise à
saignée de l'anus mais ça l'a pas arrêté
et puis il est parti en me laissant
comme ça
il m'a habillé et on m'a ramené en
confinement solitaire
en quatre mois plus de 18000 personnes
auraient été incarcérées en Iran en lien
avec les manifestations
les témoignages de mauvais traitement en
prison s'accumulent et ils incluent les
viols de femmes et aussi d'hommes
quelques-uns ont même été pendus
parmi da d'y avoir été maltraités
jusqu'à son dernier jour de détention
[Musique]
je tenus mes mains et mes pieds étaient
attachées
quelqu'un m'a poussé et je suis tombée
brutalement
je suis dit parmi da c'est la fin
octobre et les plus tôt libérée sous
caution mais début janvier son avocat
lui apprend que son procès a eu lieu
sans elle et qu'elle vient d'être
condamnée à 6 ans de prison
parmi da fait ses bagages se précipite
vers l'aéroport et laisse tout derrière
elle
j'ai un sentiment de culpabilité parce
que je suis toujours en vie et qu'il y a
beaucoup d'autres jeunes qui ont été
tués et exécutés je sens que j'ai une
dette envers eux
ils partagent son histoire pour
sensibiliser la planète à la répression
en cours dans son pays en appui aussi au
mouvement de ceux qui comme elle ont le
courage de dénoncer
[Musique]
l'avenir de ce mouvement à mon avis très
brillant
[Musique]
et bientôt il y aura des jours meilleurs
pour ce pays riche et grandiose
parmi da cherche aujourd'hui un pays
pour l'accueillir à long terme mais elle
rêve déjà de pouvoir un jour retourner
en Iran
oui j'aimerais beaucoup pour l'instant
elle est seule avec ses souvenirs et la
lourde mission qu'elle s'est donnée